como una tragedia que se repite un mes y
una semana después de la doble explosión
que arrasó con el puerto de beirut en la
misma zona se produjo un nuevo incendio
este jueves un galpón que contenía
aceite de neumáticos fue consumido por
el fuego los bomberos se apresuraron a
la escena y cruzaron las filas de
automóviles atrapados en el
embotellamiento ocasionado por
residentes que intentaban huir a la red
tuve que evacuar a mi esposa e hijos
fuera de beirut para que no vieran lo
que estaba pasando porque todavía viven
con miedo de lo que pasó han resanado la
nube cubre casi toda la ciudad teníamos
miedo porque la explosión que destruyó
beirut ocurrió hace apenas un mes y le
dan mar beirut y ahí vemos que vuelve a
suceder lo mismo en dos tanto correr
según el director interino del puerto de
beirut este fuego habría estallado por
el calor o por un error pero el gobierno
fue más allá toda faja más de raíz el
presidente libanés michel aún dice que
el incendio de hoy podría ser un acto
internacional de sabotaje el resultado
de un error técnico ignorancia o
negligencia en todos los casos la causa
debe ser conocida lo antes posible
les deben rendir cuentas mlm 10a los
testigos dicen que el almacén se
incendió mientras algunos empleados
realizaban trabajos de soldadura el
gobierno libanés solicitó una
investigación